resistance to antibiotics to treat
illness and disease is one of the big
medical challenges of the day as much
for animals as for humans no surprise
then that fighting antimicrobial
resistance lies at the heart of new
legislation being considered by any PS
on veterinary medicinal products yeah I
must even understand antibiotic are
guarded in it Tia must with Mia and the
beautycon because under t retired at San
cleric you mentioned when customers
faith dismiss my ring and Corrigan MEP s
believe a comprehensive approach is
needed limiting the use of
antimicrobials to case-by-case treatment
of disease rather than for prevention
plus restricting wider use when only one
animal in a group is hit by disease
parliament is considering an overhaul of
a regulation dating back to two thousand
and one encouraging innovation in
production and bringing the
authorization and distribution of
medicines up to date it facilitates the
access to medicinal products and also it
facilitates the transport and
circulation of medicines across the EU
many specialists argue that change and
harmonization is long overdue in a
market which is small but highly
fragmented